bonjour andré lesueur
bonjour bonjour à tous et aux salles et
un taux particulièrement maire de
rivière salée justement depuis 1989
c'est ce que vous êtes et vous êtes
également depuis 2008 il faut le
rappeler également président des forces
martiniquaises de progrès andré lesueur
celles et ceux qui nous écoutent en
radiodiffusion et nous regardent sur le
web feront vite le calcul 1989 2020 et
vous avez semble-t-il toujours et encore
la motivation pour tenter un nouveau
mandat pourquoi en effet si je suis
encore là c'est tout simplement parce
que les salles et 1 l'ont voulu
pourquoi rj prolonge ses mandats tout
simplement je vais être franc avec vous
j'ai le sentiment d'être réquisitionnés
d'abord par la majorité
les salles et du conseil municipal mais
aussi par le peuple
ils veulent que je revienne et je ne
veux pas les décevoir
donc je suis prêt à poursuivre
puis à faire des choses à poursuivre le
travail entamé
nous avons entamé une transformation de
la salle et j'ai presque envie de dire
une métamorphose et nous entendons
continuer sur cette voie alors
réquisitionner c'est un terme qui font
ce qui est connotée effort qui vaut son
pesant mais alors certes réquisitionnée
mais vous même à titre personnel vous
andré lesueur est ce que vous ne
ressentez pas tout de même forme de ne
serait-ce que de début d'usure du
pouvoir et des équipes peut-être
j'ai la passion de ma commune de super
skis de ça et je suis assez satisfait du
jeu même envie de dire fier du travail
accompli
quoique les salles et 1 le 10 et le
reconnaître alors nous allons poursuivre
dans cette même direction en cette même
voie et il s'agit pour nous d'aller plus
avant plus loin encore et je vous le
disais tout à l'heure
il ya de nombreux chantiers qui les
attendent ils le savent on y viendra
mais justement pour engager ces
chantiers pouvoir
les aboutir il faut des moyens
de ce point de vue là comment se porte
la municipalité salle et n beaucoup
beaucoup de villes se plaignent de ne
plus avoir suffisamment de moyens de
l'état bon on va pas refaire toute la
situation tirez vous vous un bon bilan
notamment de cette mandature l'acquis
sur le point de s'achever
alors comme toutes les communes et les
dotations diminué et c'est à chacun le
sait mais il gère ça l'est on peut le
dire et bien gérée nous ne connaissons
pas de déficit chronique comme ça se
passe ailleurs nous avons un budget
équilibré mais ça ne s'est pas fait tout
seul un bain c'est au prix de lourds
sacrifices et ça ne se voit pas nous
n'allons pas pleurer sur les chaumières
mais nous faisons le job en toute
conscience et nous avons déjà 5 5 et guy
libe est-ce que rivière salée reste une
ville attractive
parce qu'elle a la concurrence de
certaines villes nous soit voisine ou
pas si éloigné que ça saleh n'est plus
la porte du sud à le dire sans vergogne
peut-être qu'on va trouver ça a peu
prétentieux et bien salée et la capitale
du sud
mais le sera encore davantage avec les
investissements lourds que nous allons
mettre en place et qui sont déjà en
partie entamée la capitale du sud
dites vous est ce que ces dernières
années notamment au cours de cette
mandature la communauté d'agglomération
parce que ce sont des élections
municipales et communautaires
est-ce que l'espace sud a justement est
suffisamment considérer rivière salée
comme vous le dites je reprends vos
propres termes comme la capitale du sud
alors je veux pas trop parler de cette
communauté qui est un fonctionnement ont
peu particulier je considère qu'on ne
prend pas assez en considération les
desiderata des élus mais je dis à mes
collègues aussi qu'il faut qu'ils
viennent avec des projets sympathique
des projets intercommunaux
il faut pas qu'on imagine que la
communauté va se substituer à
l'obligation qui leur est faite
on a l'impression que quand on ne peut
pas faire quelque chose on s'en
débarrasse en transférant la communauté
c'est faux de toute façon il ya ce qu'on
appelle les attributions de compensation
ça veut dire que tout ce que vous avez
transférer vous le payez et donc la
communauté agit
suffisamment à mon goût exemple la zone
de maupeou ça traîne un peu vous auriez
l'ambition l'intention d'être peut-être
aussi président de l'espace sud pour la
prochaine mandature si vous êtes réélu
maire de rivière salée
je ne sais pas lire dans le marc de café
jeunes un jury jamais l'avenir
il ya des élections municipales et si
mes collègues considèrent que j'ai la
capacité l'envergure le charisme
l'expérience qu'il faut pour la diriger
pourquoi pas mais jusqu'à nouvel ordre
et un président les oui mais ce sont les
choses se poursuivent et améliorant
renouvellement du à des élections et
vous m'avez très bien très rapidement
quelques mots qu'elle sera lequel quel
serait le champi le chantier
emblématique de votre prochaine
mandature pour y verser à chacun de ses
soeurs secret de polichinelle la
reconstruction de l'hôtel de ville les
travaux devant du grès démarré le 20 le
20 janvier
ils ont duré à peu près deux ans pour un
coût de 10 millions d'euros
il n'y a pas que ça nous sommes en train
de réhabiliter l'église petit bourg
notre dame de la visitation
les travaux sont bien avancés nous
espérons qu'ils seront livrés d'ici
avril me mais pour deux millions six
d'euros l'école mixte
ah non on n'a plus le temps se demander
le champion emblématique allait en
appeler en niant pas voilà et deux
dernières écoles sur les huit qui glisse
nous sommes en train de les mettre aux
normes parasismiques aux encours global
de 5 millions d'euros
merci andré lesueur c'est moi qui vous
remercie